Five open source repositories, over
500,000 GitHub stars between them. Put
together, they are the essential toolkit
for building an AI agent in 2026. Not
10, not 20, five. The five doing the
actual work. Because an agent needs
exactly four things. A way to read the
web, a way to act on it, a memory, and a
brain to plan. These five fill every one
of those slots, and one of them does two
jobs at once. Here is the map we are
going to build piece by piece. First
surprise, the most starred repo on this
list is not an agent framework at all.
It is a web scraper. And number four is
the open- source answer to a coding tool
that costs $500 a month and went viral
because a startup thought they could
charge that forever. We count all five
in order and every single one is free
and open. By the end, you will know
exactly which to reach for and which
slot it fills. Number five, browser use.
It hands an AI agent a real web browser
and lets it click, type, and scroll like
a person. You give it a goal in plain
English, book this flight, pull these
prices, fill out this form, and it
drives the page itself, one step at a
time, reading whatever is on the screen.
The loop is what makes it work. It reads
the page structure, decides the next
action, clicks or types, then looks
again at the new state. No brittle
recorded script. It adapts when a site
changes under it. That opens up the
whole world of sites that have no API.
Filling long forms, running a checkout
end to end, pulling a number off a
dashboard behind a login. If a person
can do it in a browser, this can
automate it. And it holds up under
testing. On Web Voyager, a benchmark of
586 real tasks across live websites. The
team reported finishing about 89% of
them. It is model agnostic, so you plug
in whatever brain you like, and there is
a hosted cloud version if you would
rather not run browsers yourself, but
the core is MIT licensed and free. It
came out of almost nowhere. The project
only opened up in late 2024, and it grew
fast enough that a startup formed around
it, and a whole cottage industry of
browser agents followed in its wake. One
real limit before we move on. A browser
agent is slower and pricier than a clean
API call. And a strange pop-up can still
trip it up. Reach for it when no API
exists. Not for everything. 106,000
stars on a repo barely a year and a half
old. One of the fastest climbs on all of
GitHub. That is the hands of your agent.
Slot one filled. Number four. Firecrawl.
If browser uses the hands, firecrawl is
the eyes. It turns a messy website into
clean structured data. Point it at any
URL and it hands back tidy markdown or
JSON. No ads, no cookie banners, no
navigation clutter, just the content in
the shape a language model can actually
read. One API, four verbs, scrape a
single page, crawl a whole site, search
the web, and get the results as data or
extract the exact fields you describe in
plain English. And it renders JavaScript
so single page apps come back whole. It
also handles the annoying parts for you.
Rotating proxies, anti-bot walls, even
clicking and scrolling before it grabs
the page. You send a link, you get back
clean text. That is the whole pitch. It
began as a tool inside a company called
Mendable. Got open- sourced and took off
so hard the company reorganized around
it. Now, the surprise I promised.
Firecrawl sits at over 155,000 stars,
the most on this entire list. The single
most popular repo here is not an agent
framework. It is a web scraper. There is
a reason for that. Almost every
retrieval pipeline starts by getting the
web in and firecrawl makes that first
ugly step disappear. Feed it in as clean
markdown and everything downstream gets
easier. Open source with a hosted option
on top so you can call the cloud or run
it yourself. Slot two, reading the
world. Done. Number three, mem zero
memory for AI agents. Start with the
problem it fixes. By default, an agent
forgets everything the moment a chat
ends. Every session starts from a blank
slate. It cannot learn your name, your
preferences, or what you told it five
minutes ago. The naive fix is to paste
the entire chat history back in every
turn. Do that and you blow through the
context window and the token bill within
a day. Mem0 is the smarter middle path.
It works in two phases. It pulls the
durable facts out of a conversation and
stores them. Then next time it pulls
back only the relevant ones, not the
entire transcript crammed into the
prompt. Those memories live in a vector
store with an optional graph mode that
tracks how facts connect to each other.
Self-host the whole thing or use their
cloud. Either way, memory follows the
user, not the chat window. And it is
backed by a peer-reviewed paper, which
is rare on this list. Against the
model's built-in memory on a long
conversation benchmark, MEM0 scored 26%
more accurate, [snorts] used 90% fewer
tokens, and cut tail latency by 91%.
90% fewer tokens is the line to
remember. That is real money saved on
every single call and a faster reply on
top of it. 61,000 stars. Slot three, the
memory is in. Number two, open hands.
This is the slot nobody expected and it
is the fastest growing repo on this list
right now. Openhand started as a
community response to Devon, the AI
software engineer from Cognition AI that
launched in early 2024 at $500 a month
and made everyone realized that an agent
could finally write real code, run
tests, fix bugs, and open pull requests
on its own. The open source community's
answer was immediate. We can build that
and it should be free. What OpenHands
does is give an AI agent a complete
sandbox developer environment, a real
terminal, a code editor, a browser for
reading documentation, a file system.
You hand it a GitHub issue or a task
description in plain English. Write a
function that does X. Fix the failing
test. Add this feature to the repo and
it does what a human developer would do.
It reads the relevant files, plans an
approach, writes the code, runs the
tests, sees what broke, and iterates
until the task is done. That loop is not
a demo trick. It is benchmarked.
Openhands posts its results publicly on
swbench, the standard test suite for AI
coding agents. That kind of transparency
does not exist for most dollar 500 a
month alternatives.
>> [snorts]
>> It supports over 100 model backends, so
you can run it against Claude, GPT,
Gemini, or a local model. Self-host the
whole thing on your own server for free.
MIT license throughout the story of this
repo in one line. A $500 closed source
product launched. The open- source
community said no and built a better
one. 82,000 stars in climbing slot four,
the coding agent that closes real
tickets. Number one, Defy, the brain.
And on this list, it is also the
biggest. Defy is the full production
platform for building, deploying, and
operating AI applications and agents all
on a visual canvas. You drag in a model
node here, a retriever there, a tool
call over there. Connect them with lines
and the data flows through while you
watch. It started where Langlow did as a
visual way to wire agents together and
kept going until it became the platform
you actually ship with, not just a
prototype tool, a platform for
production. Here is what separates it.
When a workflow breaks in production on
most visual builders, you are guessing.
Defi ships with perstep logging, timing
traces, and open telemetry export, so
you can see exactly which step fired,
with what input, and where it slowed
down. It also has a built-in worker ceue
so longunning flows do not time out on
your users. Those are not features you
bolt on later. They are baked in from
the start, and it handles the full
knowledge stack natively. Drop your
documents in and it builds retrieval
over them. No separate rag setup, no
glue code. Multi-agent orchestration,
prompt management, A/B testing, user
analytics, and app publishing, all on
the same screen. The same canvas you
prototyped in is the canvas you deploy
from. The numbers back it. Defi crossed
100,000 stars in June 2025 and is passed
145,000 by mid 2026. It runs on more
than 1.4 million machines across 175
countries. Enterprise customers include
Marisque, Novartis, Deote, and
Panasonic. In early 2026, the company
raised $30 million at a $180 million
valuation with Apache 2.0 staying on the
core the whole time. 145,000 stars and
the most complete platform on this list,
the brain, the planner, and the front
door allin one. Slot five filled and
then some. And that is all five. Before
we assemble them, look one more time at
what just landed. The most popular repo
here is a web scraper. The fastest
growing is an answer to a $500 payw
wall. And the biggest platform nobody is
arguing about on Twitter is quietly
running on 1.4 million machines. Here is
where it gets fun. No single one of
these five is the whole answer. But snap
them together and you get something that
starts to feel like an actual employee.
Take a real useful job. Find information
on the web. Remember what matters. Write
code that acts on it and run the whole
thing without anyone watching. Watch
which repo does each part. Firecrawl
reads the pages and hands back clean
data. Browser use clicks through
anything that needs a real session. Mem
zero remembers what you care about
between runs. Openhands writes and runs
the actual code when the task needs a
developer. And DFI is the canvas that
ties all of it together into a workflow
you can actually ship. Five repos, one
working system. And notice what you did
not do. Write memory from scratch. Build
a retrieval pipeline from zero. Stand up
a sandbox coding environment by hand.
You wired five well-worn parts together.
Each doing the one thing it is best at.
Every slot is covered. Eyes on the web.
Hands on the browser. A memory that
persists. A coding agent that closes
tickets. And a production brain that
runs the whole relay. Keep this cheat
sheet. Reading the web. Fire crawl.
Acting on the web. Browser use. Memory.
Mem zero coding agent open hands
orchestration and deployment defy. That
is the real point of this list. You do
not build an AI agent from scratch
anymore. You assemble it from parts. And
these are the five parts with the
biggest communities and the most battle
testing behind them because everyone is
open source. There are no seat licenses,
no vendor lockin, and no blackbox. You
can read exactly how your agent thinks
and change any piece you do not like.
The price of this entire stack, nothing
to download, read or run. You pay only
for the model calls you make, but you do
not need all five to start. Pick two.
Firecrawl to pull data in and defy to
run the loop. Get that working first,
then grow the stack outward from there.
And keep in mind how fast this moves.
Several of these repos did not exist 3
years ago, and more than a few doubled
their stars in the last 12 months. The
map you just learned will keep shifting
under you. It bends to whoever you are.
A solo dev who wants an agent by the
weekend. A startup that cannot rebuild
memory and retrieval from scratch. A
company that needs every bite on its own
servers. One fair warning to take with
you. Stars measure attention, not fit.
Judge each repo by what it solves today,
not by the size of its badge. All five
repos, every link in their star counts
are down in the description. If this
saved you a week of digging, subscribe
and go star the ones you are actually
going to